Duanwu Festival, which is also known as Dragon Boat Festival...
...is a traditional and statutory holiday originating in China.
It's associated with a number of East Asian and Southeast Asian traditions...
...in Vietnam, Singapore, and Malaysia.
In Mandarin, it's known as Duanwujie.
The festival is held on the fifth day of the fifth month of the Chinese lunar calendar.
The date varies from year to year on the Gregorian calendar.
The festival is best known for its dragon boat races,...
...which has become a spectacular event in China,...
...especially in southern provinces where there are many rivers and lakes.
The dragon boat racing tradition stems from the legends...
...that local people had paddled out in similar style long boats...
...as they tried to retrieve Qu Yuan's body after he had drowned in the river.
After the starting pistol is fired,...
...the boat racing dragon-shaped canoes glide through the water,...
...accompanied by the beating of drums.